well spring finally finally huh that's
not something I heard a lot of people
saying when they announced a rage to
sequel but here we are
I'm Peter Brown with Jordan and Jordan
remai and we are looking at footage of
rage - and you recently saw this game I
saw it a few months back but you saw a
lot more than me Jordan so how did your
demo begin of this very unlikely sequel
well it started exactly like this
walking into this town that was lit up
by all these neon lights and filled with
all these people talking and I kind of
got the gist that this was what the game
was going to be about kind of very
personable talking to people maybe even
telling a really good story
unfortunately that's not exactly what I
got and there were some aspects of recha
- that I really enjoyed but this opening
didn't exactly sell what the overall
experience was going to be I think to
talk about the overall experience we
also have to sort of compare and
contrast a little bit with the original
game yeah did you play much of that or
any of it yeah I did kind of before this
and then after playing with a demo for
it played some of Rage so I could get
some comparison to what the first game
was yeah for anyone who hasn't played
the original it was and it not really
positioned as an open-world game but
some people maybe incorrectly look back
on it as one yeah oh really it was a
bunch of you know levels that were
connected by roads for the most part it
didn't feel like you could really
explore the open world and get a lot out
of it but this time around but des des
has partnered with Avalanche Studios you
know known for just cause Mad Max games
like that and they're promising a big
open world thing with this sort of
newfound like neon attitude and yeah as
you said you know they're trying to
entice people with a story here but what
was it that you felt was particularly
lacking at gas based on your experience
well probably the most notable thing
that kind of was very lacking about the
game was specifically surprisingly the
driving mechanics like you wouldn't have
expected the driving to be in notice of
poor aspect of Rage to you especially
with it like getting help specifically
with that part of the game yet it felt
no better than kind of what you would
get with Borderlands 2 where you can
accelerate you can go backwards and you
can boost occasionally and shoot but the
controls aren't very refined and they
feel a little bit loose with some of the
vehicles like I wasn't expecting Forza
but still at the same time I didn't
really get the driving experience that I
was expecting did you get a sense of
like like physics to the car models or
the driving at all or did it seem like
really stiff just animation so if you
know what I mean yeah some of the cars
had different physics if that kind of
makes sense like the monster car was a
little bit more bouncy if it went off of
a ramp and then landed in a specific way
the lighter cars went a little bit
higher off of ramps as opposed to the
larger cars that were probably a little
bit heavier but for the most part it
also kind of felt like many of the cars
felt like they drove exactly the same
now that said with the demo that we got
to play the garage was closed so I could
do no car customizations for all I know
that gets very different later on
sure you know some but you you have this
car cars and you're in an open world
that they are now really boasting is
that and they're you know they're
throwing around things like different
weather effects and like you know you
find random enemies out in the world
like what was the feeling of driving
around in that space as someone who is a
target I almost never felt like I was
the target of anyone elses aggression
which was a little bit surprising I
always felt like I was wandering into
someone else's story I probably wandered
into some old man who was being chased
by bandits half a dozen times in the
hour and a half that I was playing the
game in or I would run into bandit camps
and I would be the one who was kind of
invading them not the other way around
it never really felt like the game was
centered around me more so that I was
wandering into these stories that were
already in motion and choosing whether
or not to participate in them yeah the
what about these sort of you know the
tone we're looking at for this game is
very
like over the top how did that mesh with
the different characters that were
presents the characters are unique in a
way like they're crazy and they're not
characters you would normally see in
another type of game but they are all
characters that you probably would have
expected to see in something that was
post-apocalyptic like we're kind of like
looking at a character right now he's
the one who does all the races and stuff
like that and his whole shtick is that
he just loves meat and so he just makes
a bunch of like meat puns and keeps
referencing meat all the time
that's his entire spiel he's just this
white hillbilly dude who just likes
eating just a giant steak and he has
like a drumstick in his hand at all
times he's a really deep character as
what you're saying yeah but that's kind
of the problem that's all these
characters that that kind of fit the
idea of what you would expect from a
post-apocalypse like these just crazy
characters that manage to survive and
this is kind of how they've developed
and I didn't feel like I was really
encountering something that I had never
seen before like I haven't seen this
exact character before but I've seen
characters like him before and we were
watching gameplay a little bit before of
a woman who was older a little scantily
clad and just a little bit crazy and
like I think we've seen like this
character in a bunch of other wasteland
type game right before the hedonist the
enslaver yeah and so I do wish that the
characters had been built like with a
little bit more personality and for all
I know they are they evolve in that way
I mean there's personality on the screen
if that's what you want to call it but
maybe I think I think what you're
getting at is more of a reason for them
to exist other than just being
caricatures yeah yeah because they're I
mean I can understand I can understand
like you know how this could fit if
they're just trying to like really set
the scene and just like give you some
context to laugh
but yeah if they're not totally original
in there like archetypes what do you
have here really like there's nothing
really about her character that I want
to know more about per se like there are
a few characters like that a for example
there was this kind of almost handsome
Jack asked just insane character he was
kind of interesting especially like his
paws we were playing the demo we kind of
found out that he had like a connection
to like the big bads of the game we were
like trying to take over the wasteland
I'm like so there's a little bit more to
the story there and he does seem to have
a semi interesting backstory and the
fact that it seems like he maybe or
maybe did not kill his dad in order to
get the in giant wealth that he has yeah
and he's not entirely interesting but
he's charismatic and kind of like
stupidly evil enough that you kind of do
you want to see a little bit more of him
throughout the game
or see something happen to him yeah now
do you want to actually talk about
something that the game does happen to
do very well yeah cuz yeah you did not
come back entirely negative yeah
the game does do combat fairly well like
and that's something the original rage
did as well as the gunplay it was pretty
good and this is kind of something that
its software has always done well with
doom with Wolfenstein yeah and it is
doing for those out there who don't know
it is developing all the shooting and
stuff and handing that off to avalanche
yeah so there this really is a
divide-and-conquer thing for it and an
avalanche on this project so the
gameplay itself is very loud very
boisterous it's almost impossible that I
can't even hear yourself think when it's
going on but the guns feel sharp they
feel fluid to use it feels a lot like
doom and kind of like pause the game and
you have like a weapon wheel that you
can look at with a bunch of guns and
pretty much every gun as a primary fire
and a secondary fire when you're looking
down the sights and some of
are fairly ordinary like the assault
rifle is completely Auto fry or just
wild when you shoot it normally then
when you shoot it down its secondary
fire it's basically down ironsight seem
to get a bit more accuracy at a slower
fire rate sure but others are a bit more
wild like the shotgun is a normal
shotgun as its primary fire rate and
then it does like this giant long-range
shot shock wave as it's a alternate fire
rate do you kind of mix these together
along with the powers that you have and
it makes you kind of feel like this
almost unstoppable Superman s character
and you can do a lot with the powers in
terms of like chaining them together
right like it's there's an amount of
like physics simulation in that sense
yes so if you wanted to per say there's
like four or five enemies in front of
you could throw out barrier knowing that
your barrier destroys all enemies as
soon as they touch them and then throw
vortex which would suck the enemies into
your barrier and maybe not all the
enemies die after that and so in that
moment you would use the vortexes
explosion to get enough height - then
you slam to finish off any other enemies
you're gonna chain all of these together
to do the most damage as quickly as
possible so what about the the different
venues for combat because the interior
stuff seems like it's very you know well
controlled and at least to a degree kind
of orchestrated whereas you have this
sort of like open stronghold scenario
like do you find that using your
abilities versus your weapons like takes
priority in different ways depending on
your setting yeah I found more often and
not that in these open areas I would
typically rely on the guns and almost
never use the powers because of your
reach yeah pretty much exactly almost
all of the powers are very close range
and so when you're in this kind of wide
open space you can use a dash to get up
closer to people but it's just a bit
easier and simpler to rely on a gun but
like doom for example you know getting
up and close and personal with your your
enemies was part of the experience part
of being good and constantly having
enough ammo and health
does this game do anything in that
regard to encourage you to fight up
close I think the game once to you to
find up close because all the powers
like I said are like very close range
and most of the guns seem to have like a
close arrangement this is like feedback
into the meta of why you do things not
how you do them you know what I mean
not really okay like I mean that's not
necessarily like like I think Doom was
exceptional in that sense but not every
shooter can really find a way to pull
that off uh-huh so what about the
variety of enemies that you ran into so
far a lot of the footage you've been
looking at apart from that one boss has
included just sort of like standard fare
like humans and such but we've seen
frightening abominations you know shown
in trailers did you run into any of that
sort of supernatural like mutated stuff
unfortunately no my entire time with the
game I pretty much just ran into bandits
and for the most part they were just
bandits they used guns I didn't see any
of them that use like the swords and
trailers or anything like that I did
fight a few bosses like that giant orc
monster as well as these bands that were
piloting this giant mech like thing okay
but uh how did you fight the next thing
yeah it was kind of in front of one of
these arcs and wasn't necessarily a boss
just moreso of a strong enemy okay and
those enemies are I'm not quite sure how
to feel about them they are tougher so
they do provide a bit more of a
challenge most of the enemies I fought I
was like well almost all of my powers
kill them instantly so I can't really
change a bunch of combos but the larger
enemies you have to be a bit more
strategic but at the same time you don't
you can't really do it because most of
your powers don't work on them they
typically have just one weak spot you
have to keep shooting that week's select
with the giant troll monster it's it's
head for the mech it's it's two arms and
it's back so pretty much the only thing
you can do is just
jump and shoot and so it's not as
strategic and in my opinion it's not as
enjoyable in this moment yeah and you
know and to be fair
you've played what two hours of the game
yeah about I played honestly the same 15
minute demo three times a few months
back and that was really only interior
shooting and stuff I feel like I am
incapable of like weighing in on this
game with any amount of finality I think
oh yeah even the stuff you've seen we
still need to see how that all pans out
and develop some changes but right now
you know what is sort of your general
take away what are your what were the
you know what were the quickly the
things that surprised you that you're
really looking forward to seeing more of
and what do you really want to see it in
avalanche improve upon definitely my
biggest positive is definitely the
gunplay and I hope that throughout the
game there are more instances where
battles are kind of enclosed or at least
pretty close together because it's fun
to experiment with powers and to chain
them together and I feel like when
they're just too far apart or to open it
just doesn't work as well as it's
supposed to I would also hope that the
demo I played is not an exact like
portrayal of what the open world is
going to be activity wise although the
open world is pretty kind of like the
original rage like it's graphically kind
of stunning and it's nice to look out
the sunset like over a cliff or anything
like that it didn't feel very lived in
like I wasn't getting any conversations
with people and games have like filled
that silence before with like handsome
jack broadcast Jay jonah Jameson doing
his podcast there wasn't anything like
that in the demo that I played so there
were just moments of just two and a half
minutes of driving around and not
hearing anything or doing anything and
those moments aren't a load screen but
they almost feel like one as I'm trying
to get from one mission to the next I
would love it if there's like something
in there to kind of flush it out and
give me something to do or listen to as
I'm going from one point to the next
yeah you know it's really only Bethesda
and you know avalanche and Ed can tell
us how those things will change the
footage we've been looking at right now
the stuff we've played is all
technically pre beta right so there is
time is this game coming out
this year yeah like a general like 20 19
19 yeah okay I mean you know dates to
change so we'll see how that pans out
but otherwise I mean you guys are
looking at a game that's currently
scheduled to come out this year I'd say
it's fair that we both have some
reservations and some things that we're
excited to see more of and you know
hopefully this stuff that we're
concerned about will pan out or you know
at least uh maybe some feedback can get
back to the devs and they can take their
time I don't know how a game development
works out but thank you very much Jordan
for chatting with us today and everyone
out there for listening again this is
rage 2 coming out later this year stay
tuned to game spot
hey that Ark was brimming with some
amazing gear yeah I know I'm pretty
jealous right now so keep a lid on it
will ya